look at you two you're sandra d
channeling your inner grease this week
how has that been to work on these songs
they're iconic it's been fun it's been a
lot of fun i think for us the
dance that we can relate to the most
personally in our lives especially with
each other and so we've been able to
almost not have to act this week and
it's been really great you know what i
love hearing that is there a line from
the song that's sticking out to you that
you really relate to and that it's just
speaking to you
i don't know if it's a line other than
maybe
goodbye to sandra d because i feel like
i feel like we're really seeing a new
jojo emerge these past few weeks um but
i also think it's pretty iconic that the
only dance that could cater to two girls
is going to us i haven't talked to you
yet about like sexy jojo coming out how
has that felt in the competition you
know at first it was really scary and
honestly it took jenna to be like
go yeah yeah it's going to show a little
shoulder i was like all right shoulder
then the next week she was like we're
just gonna show a little chest and i was
like
no all right and then and are you
finding confidence in that i am i am and
we actually talk about that a lot this
week um
it's all because of this one i mean it's
wild how things can single-handedly
change your life
and
this person has single-handedly changed
the way that i think about myself look
at myself feel about myself what's
changed about the way you feel about
yourself and look at yourself i'll go
into detail because it's fun and it's
interesting and it's a great story that
hasn't been really told
one day in rehearsals i was wearing a
full gymnastics leotard that was full
hideous
and a t-shirt over it
and somehow
you jenna ended up making me take my
t-shirt off
because somehow i said something no we
were in frame and i was like this is too
baggy i can't deal i know you have
something on underneath like
take it off and i was like i can't and
she was like why and i was like because
i don't like the way that i look under
it
and she was like
no and she was like you said to me you
said i'm your partner
you have to trust me
take it off like you're wearing
something under it literally take it off
and then i started crying and i took it
off and i went up to the mirror and she
made me say a lot of things to myself
that i've never said before and never
thought and now slowly but surely i'm
finding
myself i'm finding how i feel about
myself
i go into fittings now and i literally
just say i always say whatever boss
wants and i go into a spray tan now and
i didn't want to spray 10 in the
beginning but now i go into a spray tan
and i say whatever boss wants just do it
stop whenever she tells you to i don't
care because
since the moment that i trusted her with
everything it's been great and
i don't know my trust is really hard to
gain but she got it really fast my
initial reaction is like why hadn't you
had those thoughts of confidence about
yourself before i don't know if you look
at my
past you'll see a lot of my costumes are
long sleeves you'll see a lot of my
outfits are pants you'll see that i
would never wear a tank top never wear a
spaghetti strap and i just didn't like
it i always said my chest was too broad
and my shoulders were too broad and i
didn't like my little chicken nugget
thing that happens here and my arms i
didn't like and i mean literally i think
you also have to remember you know i
think everyone looks at jojo as this
like
powerhouse woman who has it all and she
does but at the end of the day she is
18. yeah and she's a girl and in dance
class you have to stare at yourself in
the mirror for hours on end and that's
not always easy and i remember when i
was 18. i didn't like it you know so and
i think we are our own worst enemies
yeah so sometimes it takes somebody else
to show you how gorgeous and stunning
you are i mean you're standing here girl
working a crop top yes showing the
shoulder yes
show that shoulder yes
look at her she's jojo siwa this feels
like a now this really feels like a good
song for this week look at me it
literally if you go from the lyrics look
at me there has to be something more
than what they see so wholesome and pure
so scared and unsure a poor man sandra d
sandy you must start anew don't you know
what you must do hold your head high
take a deep breath inside
goodbye sandra like it's literally
me how i feel about myself than her
being like
come on
no look at yourself you're fine
[Music]
do you feel like we're getting a new
jojo because you've gotten some
criticism from the judges i feel like
they're so hard on you because you're so
good
jenna's like help help please every
every week that we do rehearsals
generals say this dance is
hard just so you know like even this
week you're like this is one of the
hardest foxtrots that i've ever done
and
so therefore i
i want the judges to be harder on me
that you know what i mean like it's like
i think because of my background i think
because of my age i think because of
what i do for a living i don't want the
judges to give me a hall pass they
should rightfully so judge me a lot
harder than they do melora a lot harder
than they would the miz you know what i
mean but it's tough but
she it's not like she isn't working
harder if not harder than everybody else
you know so i do want them to recognize
that jenna are you feeling a little a
little frustrated not frustrated but i
do you know it is hard for me to sit
there and watch her be critiqued when
i'm like i wish you could see the amount
of effort that she puts in every single
day well tell me what's going into this
dance what can we expect from look at me
i'm sandra d i'm really excited about it
i think it's very different it's very
very different i feel like there's
always been a jojo and
in these last five weeks i've showed a
really different side of me going one
way going you know a little more
revealing going a little more hot going
a little more
okay
but i feel like this week i'm actually
going more wholesome and more dainty
than i have ever been and so it's a fun
another different side of me but the
dance our first day of rehearsals i
literally was like
jenna i just apologize she was like i
know it's hard and i was like i
literally feel like i'm doing a foreign
language and all i'm doing is
down up up down side turns walk for left
right but like it's an algebra problem
in my brain i can't figure it out you
are under the tutelage miss abby lee
miller who is no joke so for you to say
that this is hard i feel like that
carries weight for you to say that
listen i've learned a billion numbers in
my life i have performed a billion
different times
every single week
whatever this one choreographs is harder
wow than anything i've ever done
sandy tell me about it still i gotta
show you guys we have a little message
from the sandra d miss olivia newton
john herself she gonna be watching this
week of course i'll watch i guess i'm
i'm very much looking forward to seeing
what they do i know it's an incredibly
strenuous and difficult show to do
because my daughter was on dancing with
the stars in australia so i got to watch
rehearsal times and i'm excited to see
what they do and
um i'm sure all of us who are in the
movie can't wait to see it that's
awesome
she's watching she said of course i'll
watch i know how hard it is and i can't
wait to see what they do oh now the
pressure is oh not like it wasn't before
but
not only she could apparently be
watching at home we have frankie avalon
singing pink lady frenchie dd khan is
stopping by so how cool is it gonna be
to have the real grease alum in the
ballroom an honor unlike any before i
mean i think my mom's going to be
fangirling so hard in the audience and
it's going to be her favorite part of
the night just seeing them instead of
seeing us dance
but it's so legendary and iconic and a
day that we'll only get once
you